so my daughter just told me she uses my
toothbrush to brush the dog's teeth
how's your day going the kids walked in
on me and my wife wrestling again my son
said mommy should stop because always
sounds like she's losing my
four-year-old just told me it's okay I
love you so I might not put you in the
washing machine tonight
my son just said I have a comforting
forehead weirdest compliment ever her in
26 today my son told me I'm old like a
tree I'm gonna die soon my five year old
just asked my three year old to step
into her office she concluded the
conversation with and remember my door
is always open I want to see a mortgage
advisor with my seven year old son and
when we sat down across from his desk my
son said I'm not her husband my son said
mommy you are a terrible cook but I eat
your food because I love you and I don't
want to hurt your feelings but I don't
want to die either my young son just
told me he wants to be a hooker when
he's older he meant fishermen my
daughter told me the moon was a stalker
and I asked why she said because it's
always following me my son ran out of my
bedroom waving my blue vibrator in the
air yelling look at my new lightsaber
why do these things happen when
neighbors are over